problema número 161 el dígito positivo n
es divisible entre 25 si la raíz
cuadrada de m es mayor que 25 cuál puede
ser el valor de n entre 25
veamos si podemos manipular esto un poco
tengo que la raíz de n
es mayor que 25
y me preguntan cuál puede ser el valor
de n entre 25
eso es lo que me pregunta
vamos a elevar al cuadrado a ambos lados
de esta desigualdad nos queda n cuadrada
es mayor que 25 por 25 625
y nos dijeron que bueno ya que estamos
viendo esto m entre 25 debe ser mayor
que 25
por lo que un valor aceptable de entre
25 es que n sea mayor a 25 y viendo las
opciones sólo hay un valor de esas
opciones que es mayor a 25 y es la
opción
que tiene el valor de 26 siguiente
problema problema número 162 tenemos que
hacer esta operación donde aplicaremos
todas nuestras habilidades para
manipular fracciones esto es igual
esta parte de aquí de esta chiquita dos
enteros es lo mismo que seis tercios
seis tercios más un tercio va a ser
igual a siete tercios esta parte la
puede reescribir
cómo
uno entre siete tercios y esto es lo
mismo que tener uno esto es lo mismo que
tener uno más tres séptimos
uno entero es lo mismo que siete
séptimos
esto tengo 7 / 7 que es lo mismo que uno
entero y le sumó 3 séptimos
esto es igual a 10 séptimos
por lo tanto todo esto de aquí abajo lo
puedo poner como 1 / 10
séptimos y esto es lo mismo que tener
siete décimos y esta es mi opción b
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo